hello everybody i'm grace vinod
raja from nishi sri lanka currently
studying bioprocess informatics
at the university of weinstefan tristoff
in bayern germany
and i have a basic background in medical
biology from the university of tuisburg
essen
as a final project of the program
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
by pine bio i have chosen the topic
human bronchial organized
a 3d in vitro test model for sas
coronavirus 2.
today i would like to present our
project and the finding from our study
the influence of different human
reference genome in rna sequence
analysis
and their impact on an in vitro kovic 19
drug test with chemostat
it is a joint project with mr priyanka
silachami
also known as victor from our course
even though my partner prepared some
interesting slides about the biological
background regarding
sas coronavirus 2 he couldn't able to
present his part of the project
since he got busy with his thesis works
so let me cover the theoretical part of
our project briefly
and let me get into the technical part
which i was mainly involved in
we all know about the impact of sas
coronavirus 2
around this world and we discussed
enough about spike proteins and as2
receptor
in our cell membrane
in our project we observed tmprss2
which is transmembrane serine protease
subtype
2 which play an important role
in activating the spike proteins
according to the scientists
of the german primate center also
known as deutsches primaten syndrome
once the spike proteins get activated
the virion could attach to
our as2 receptors in cell membrane
to avoid the activation of spike protein
we are going to study about
tmprss2 and chemostat
which is also known as tmprss2
inhibitors
chemostat is approved drug in japan
which is widely used
for pancreatic inflammation
as an innovative atom by a japanese
research institute of
microbial diseases they generated human
bronchial organize out of human
bronchial epithelial cells
furthermore they applied it as a test
model for their studies
moreover in human bronchial organize
they were able to observe different cell
types
which are significant for their studies
as well as
histologically significant for any
alveolar
or bronchial tissues
such as basal cells club cells
ciliated cells and goblet cells
for our research we performed ngs
analysis
on collected sra data from their studies
which is also available in ncbi as
open resource and we conducted a study
about the differential gene
expressions using both human reference
genomes
grch37 and grch38
these are the sra data which we
collected from ncbi
and we divided them into two groups in
the first proba set
we grouped a 549 cell clients
human bronchial epithelial cells and
human bronchial organized
to study about the similarity between
the cell types
in the second probe we grouped control
human bronchial organites
which were not infected sas coronavirus
ii
contaminated human bronchial organites
and sas coronavirus contaminated and
with chemostat treated human bronchial
organize
coming next to our problem statements
so we wanted to study about the impact
of different
reference genomes grch37 and 38
throughout our analysis
a differential gene expression studies
among the control
infected and treated human bronchial
organize
a control test to analyze contamination
of our probe too
as mentioned different pipelines of
transcriptomics
analysis were performed using both human
reference genomes separately
so grch37 and grch38
for each sets of probes
then the gene expression table were
quantile normalized
then a principal component analysis was
performed to study
the gene expression similarity within
the groups
in each proba set
the differential gene expression
analysis was performed
within each type of sample
in group two in probe one
it was only performed between human
bronchial epithelial cells
and human bronchial organize
finally we plotted the differential gene
expressions
on the available pathway diagrams
to precisely investigate the influence
of the reference genomes as a meta
genomic part of our study
a metagenomic microbiome analysis
pipeline was performed using all viruses
as a reference genome then the read
count of
different virus genome were obtained
from the pipeline output file
and the rate of all the coronavirus
genome were extracted out of the table
and annotated with the help of excel
tableau
and ncbi viral genome list
we performed a lot of pipelines but only
important results out of our
investigation
will be discussed here
from our analysis report of provost 1 we
were able to get results
from different transcriptomic pipelines
and
the results were identical in both grch
38
and grch37 we could observe a clear
grouping
in our principal component analysis
report as well
at the same time organized are more
alike to
human bronchial epithelial cells
comparing with
a549 cell lines
in our differential gene expression
analysis we did not observe any
significant differences
which was influenced by the reference
genome
dendrogram of our heat maps looks
identical in both human reference
genomes
and there is neither major different was
observed in volcano plot
moving on to the cake pathways we were
able to
observe additional differential gene
expressions
for grch38 in steroid hormone
biosynthesis pathway
and hematopoietic cell lineage pathway
as next moving into the second probe
we had issue performing transcriptomic
pipelines with their preference
genome grch38 although
with the grch37 we were able to obtain
resource
we were not able to conclude anything
about the quality of our
pro or pipeline errors since we were
able to get results for the grch37
moreover we had results for provo one
for both grch37
and 38 then a transcriptomic analysis
pipeline using sailfish method was
performed
without any preprocessing to get the
read table without any errors
in our principle component analysis we
were not able to
observe a clear grouping as we observed
in provo one
then we decided to do a batch correction
however we were convinced to continue
without batch correction as the scatter
plot
after batch correction looks so
artificial
we could see a clear separation between
control organized
and contaminated organoids although
there is no significant separation
observed
between infected and treated organoids
we proceeded with the differential gene
expression analysis
as a differential gene expression
analysis could be performed
among two sets of samples we performed
the analysis
in three further groups one
control and infected human bronchial
organize
to study the gene expressions while the
human bronchial organize is infected
secondly the control and treated human
bronchial organize
to see whether we could apply it as a
method to study
the side effect of our drug
thirdly we analyzed the infected and
treated human bronchial organize
in order to see the significant gene
expression throughout the treatment
from our differential gene expression
analysis between control and infected
human bronchial organoids
we could not witness any vital influence
of
different version of human reference
genome
the dendrogram looks similar in both
heat maps
only some of the gene were differently
arranged
on their rows volcano plot is
also comparable however
there is a notable difference in gene
expressions
between control and infected organoids
the differential gene expression
analysis between control
and treated human bronchial organize
also did not
show any notable influences of the
reference genome
the endogram of the heat maps look the
same
as a previous result there is a notable
difference in gene expression between
control and treated organites but the
differential gene expression analysis
between
infected and treated human bronchial
organize
does show us a difference in gene
expressions
which was influenced by a reference
genome
the dendrograms shows the different
groupings
depend on different genome and
there is a notable difference seen in
volcano plots
as well
moving on to the differential gene
expression analysis on
kick pathways we did not observe any
significant difference among the control
and infected organoids or
controlled or treated organoids
but there was an additional pathway
observed in differential expression
analysis
on kick pathways for reference genome
grch38
which shows the down expression in
pentose
and gluconate interconnections pathway
on treated bronchial organize it could
be
significant for the biochemical or
physiological
signaling pathway investigation of
bronchial orgonites
as an effect of chemostat treatment
as there was significant difference
noted in the heat maps
and the volcano plots of control
organized and the treated organized
the remarkable difference was expected
in their cake pathway analysis too
as mentioned in a slide we were able to
see
completely different pathways analysis
diagrams
depend on the human reference genomes
even though there is there are six kick
pathways that were
common among the both reference genomes
there were some unique pathways observed
for each reference genome
which probably important evidence for
signaling pathway studies
of this experiment those are the
important data
and visualizations from our
transcriptomics part
of this study
okay let's move on to the meta genomic
part of our research
although there isn't any clear evidence
to prove
that the control organites were not
contaminated
we could observe there's a difference in
their counts
for example the infected organized shows
some
more counts than the control organites
additionally we could observe the
absence of sas coronavirus1
which is hku1 in control
and treated samples which was but
founded in
infected organoid it is an interesting
topic to be
analyzed furthermore
as we looked into the significant genes
for the basal cell
club cells ciliated cells and goblet
cells
we could recognize that the tmpr ss2
s2 uh cc10
fgf1 ifn1
genes are very unique for the human
bronchial
as the research is all about tmp rss2
inhibitor
it is evident that the organized are the
best study model
among them for this research
about the second table we could see
the difference in tmp rss2 expressions
comparing
with infected organoids two third of
the treated organites show less tmp iss
expressions which is almost similar to
the expressions level
of those control organoids although
chemostat
shows the positive response as tmp
rss2 inhibitor we cannot conclude it
as a successful medicine for sas
coronavirus 2
because the experiment was conducted
among
three sets of organoids finally
then we come to the conclusions and
finding from our study
there are some differences noted in our
differential gene expression analysis
which was influenced by the reference
genome
especially the differences were
significant among organoids
but we were not able to choose a better
version
among them for a better data driven
research it is recommended to use both
reference genome
for a wide analysis
although we face some problem producing
a gene read count table for organized
using a reference genome
grch38 in few pipelines
we were able to investigate the
differential gene expression
analysis using the selfish method
so it is also important to try
different pipelines methods for a better
results
we were able to summarize all the
differential expression
of significant genes about 33 cake
tables
which could be a breakthrough for new
biochemical and physiological researches
about sas coronavirus 2 and human
bronchial organize
and its signaling pathway studies
further investigation on this topic may
lead us
to the invention of new pathways and
alternation
in the existing pathways as we noticed
theoretically
influencer a pathway is additional
information
for our study precisely the hsa
one six four cake pathway table
a study comparing a human bronchial
organize
and pulmonary tissue biopsy could give
us a real breakthrough
in the development of human organoids as
a drug of vaccine test models
especially it could help pharmaceutical
industries
scientists and medicine to avoid
unexpected outbreaks during their
experiment
on living test models it could also help
us to reduce
the consumption of time as the organize
could be manufactured quickly than other
living
test models thank you
finally i would like to thank for
elia and pine bio for giving us a
interesting uh program and the
opportunity to present our research
project
and uh i would like to thank pine bio
educational platform
and server platform rstudio
which helped me uh in some of the data
visualizations
and uh research institute for microbial
disease
who initiate the core research which we
chosen later on and ncbi for providing
the sra datas
and bio rxiv the preprint server for
biology
and my universities for providing us
informations on coronavirus and
my former uniclinic where i could still
access
my histology preparates
and nishi for introducing pinewood in
sri lanka
thank you
you